[Music]
i think a lot of people didn't
understand gymnastics like the twisties
is there any worry that when you guys
get brutally exhausted after 35 dates on
this that that same thing can pop up it
can happen anytime obviously i'm not
twisting on tour so it can't happen
so thank god but it just shows how much
stress anxiety and pressure that is put
on us and we put on ourselves whenever
we go out onto those global scenes
how's it been in the aftermath of the
olympics that bravery um overwhelming
amount of love and support and of
outreach of fans
family
and it's just been insane it shines a
whole new light on the spore and
ourselves as not just an athlete but as
a human
[Music]
these ladies have been working hard for
the athleta presents gold over america
35 city tour it's tumbling and there's
dance and it's super super cool it is
things that you see us compete but for
us it's kind of no big deal it's easy so
skills we can throw every night and it's
not too taxing on our body how much more
difficult is it to be in the spotlight
in the complete dark upside down
flipping on a beam that's this big we
kind of have spotlights here and there
to where we can kind of see the floor
but other than that i feel like we know
our bodies very well
how do you get ready to entertain an
entire arena of people well it's been
really hard when we first came we had 13
hour days for like four or five days so
we're kind of exhausted we ordered an
ice bath we're sleeping on a bus and
then on our days off we're in a hotel so
it's kind of been a little bit of an
adjustment but i mean we've been through
a lot harder things so i feel like we're
actually pretty good right now one two
three four five six seven eight
missing from the lineup suny lee who
made her dancing with the star's debut
last week but her teammates were
watching including mirrorball trophy
winner lori hernandez i think she did so
well i'm so proud of her and then of
course we have val and jenna that are up
there too i mean
val to this day is someone that i look
up to um and we will still either
facetime here and there or text and
whatnot um so we've definitely kept in
touch over the years and i just i love
him to pieces suny word of advice use
chapstick for the blisters that are
going to get all over your feet because
of the heels
do your best not to roll your ankles but
if it happens just walk it out girl it's
so much better to walk it out than just
sit down
and try not to step on sasha's toes
because i did that with val a lot and i
feel very bad to this day five years
later
[Applause]
[Music]
you